اولا ما رايكم بهذا التصنيف لافضل مطربي
العالم في التاريخ 200 مطرب
طبعا احنا يعني اول ما شفت الخبر انه
اختياره ام كلثوم ضمن افضل 200 مطرب او
مطربه في العالم
الخبر في حد ذاته خبر سعيد بالنسبه لي لكن
سريعا ما همم على التفكر لما شفت الترتيب
وان هي رقمها 61 وسط الاعظم حسيت شويه انه
الموضوع لا في بعض
في بعض الظن شويه لتاريخها والمشروعها
خاصه انه حيثيات اختيارها او اختيار ال
200 مطرب كانت قائمه على فكره التاثير
العميق للفنان في و- مشوار التاريخ ولو
حسبنا كويس هنلاقي انه من اعظم المشروعات
ال- همم الغنائيه والموسيقيه في همم في
التاريخ العربي كله وهمم ومن اعظمهم في
العالم طبعا المشروع الفني لام كلثوم يعني
المراه التي تربت على عرش غناء لاكثر من
50 سنه من حياتها همم منذ العشرينات وحتى
يعني حتى راحلها سنه 75 وهي
الاكثر شهره والاكثر تاثيرا في المشروع
الغنائي العربي فكان من ال- اا من الافضل
يعني ومن المفترض انه ما يكونش فيه بعض
التحيز للامر يعني بانه ام كلثوم تكون في
مكانه متقدمه شويه يعني كده